Okay.
Hello folks.
We are live.
Uh but we're going to see if we can get
some stuff done.
some basics.
We have a couple things uh that we can
play with.
All right.
Um, so if I recall,
we had a moderately successful first
sweep on breakout. Yeah.
Yeah. Jeez. 4 seconds. That's
ridiculous. It's not a full full solve,
right? Um I think it's 5 seconds for a
full solve, but still that's ridiculous.
Yeah. So this is the
2048 policy.
Newer Puffer PO params
need more sweeping
and the num mini batches. I believe this
is still uh replay ratio 1
cuz 32 * 32 768
64 Wait, hang on. Yes, 64 cuz that's the
horizon. That's correct. So, why don't
we just do um
And I don't know if we have the encoder
correct for this.
1.2 mil SPS is not terrible.
4 and a half million parameter model.
Yeah, that's probably good.
Let's go take a quick look. Make sure we
have it correct.
because we have G2048. So this is the
porch model.
And what is um
see what's different with this LSTM?
Oh, I think it's just the decoder is a
little silly
and it's no big deal
320 sport.
Yeah. See, this is still um an hour and
an hour 40 minutes is very long for
this.
Yeah, this is the problem. This end is
like
It's very weird though like this whole
encoder right
three linear layers plus scaler right so
it's pause hang on value embedding
pause embedding is numbum grid cells
33 * 225 Five.
Protein sweep purpose. So much better.
Puffer's crazy good. Yeah, Tim, we're
working on um with 40, we can do like
300 breakout experiments an hour for the
sweep. I'm trying to get it on some like
uh more interesting environments though,
right? Because breakout is the the
simplest one that's meaningful.
So value embed.2 two target DT type
right
value embed
and then you flatten
you summon flatten
So I guess then the um the question
would be if I just do like simple
So if I do like
simple
encoder
because the the hypothesis here is just
going to be that um we hopefully should
not need all this stuff anymore.
Turn.
You don't even put the linear on it cuz
why bother?
I mean, I did this for consistency, but
I think
let's just do simple
default
and we'll see how fast we can get this
to run as well.
This is me just having past Python into
C++. Let's not do that.
So, we're going to see now how fast we
can get this thing.
H. See, the SPS here is actually quite
slow.
What on earth is this?
Oh,
curve test from here.
It's really simple. Yeah.
All right,
let's just um
Uh 12 million SPS.
So yeah, this should totally be fast.
Why the hell is this slow?
Oh, actions are double
types are correct. written
a short bio.
Thanks, Finn. Working on Oro a bit.
Do keep reminding me about that talk so
I remember to make some slides
and I'll come up with some fun stuff to
talk about.
Get a little bit of stuff on MMO, a
little bit of stuff from like puffer and
a little bit of like brand new stuff
from the research.
And I'm going to have to get myself back
into talking mode for that.
When I'm kind of just here doing
research for months on end, it becomes
very difficult to even speak complete
sentences. My mind is all just like
code.
It's all just code.
I wonder if it's this model is just that
bad.
Where were you talk?
Is the thing open or not been? Um, it's
a thing for their university,
right? University. Yes, that's what I
agreed to.
Good luck with 40. It's pretty cool,
Ben. It is. Uh oh, actually, one of the
problems we have right now, I added
continuous action support yesterday. I
cannot get the drone to train with
either uh continuous or discrete
actions.
So, if you want to help before the
release making sure the drone m trains
correctly in 40, that would be great.
I added a continuous test environment
that works fully. So,
I think I don't know if there's
something wrong with either the latest
version of it or the way it's bound or
so I did something screwy, but something
ain't right.
No,
it's just like n we're going to be 2.3
million ships app. Thank you very much.
Annoying.
Hey, Hinker.
I think there is something scurry with
our ve, right?
It can't be the policy that's slow on
this.
Can't be the data transferred. It's
tiny.
Boro drone bless his stuff. Uh the good
news Finn is that the M uh the M's
themselves there's very very little
changing that is required
most of the complexity is going into
uh kernel optimization cudraphing that
type of
This is not It's not good when you have
it like this.
Okay, there's definitely vex brewiness.
Yes.
Yeah, this looks good, right?
Well, it's very oscilly.
Is this faster or slower?
But I don't see any reason why we should
do this. I think we should just do like
two
five seven up to six.
two five seven up to six. Yeah, that's
Yeah, that's
fine.
I mean definitely something wrong with
uh working title. We can go with puffer
lib reinforcement learning 10,000 times
faster.
10,000x faster.
This is still the majority of the
computers in Eval.
Yeah. Okay. So, it's definitely
screwing.
Okay, I think with this we can probably
sweep, right?
Let's try this one. I think that this is
fine. I think um
there are total time steps on this
sweep.
Let's see if I can just get something to
train reasonable. 500 mil.
It's a one minute run. That's plenty
fast.
This doesn't have milan skill. I mean um
move high skill. It is
Oh yeah, look at that. Way better,
right?
Unstable.
Really
creating a chess game right now. Uh
we've got Jess and um yo, we have an
active project on chess. Have you seen
it
or is that what you're using?
The bot just beat uh what is it? 1650
Maya ELO.
well that's 2048 in like 30 seconds,
guys.
Uh, okay. That's better than me at the
game like instantly. It's very unstable.
Without alpha search is crazy. Oh yeah.
But it's going to be better.
I think we'll have a GM bot.
man training is so unstable. Why? Why is
this
clip cover?
This is a ridiculously aggressive.
Can I just like set some more
reasonable?
Model size selection. No thinking
process, Tim. We just throw it into the
hyper pram sweep.
Start with something fast though. Like
you start with something fast that at
least does is stable and gives a
reasonable perf and then the sweep
figures everything else out.
You should not be manually tuning
hyperparameters.
2048 is like incredibly unstable.
I wonder if it's just these shitty
hypers though.
It very well could be if I just run this
for 250. Is this or like 200 mil?
>> Yeah, just sweep everything, Tim. Like I
didn't spend both Kyouong and I have
spent a couple months of our lives like
making hyper pram sweeps. Good. It's so
that you use it
and down sample on this.
Not do that.
Having X open AI in the bio. Don't do
that.
Yeah, don't do that, Ben.
If I if you put that there, I didn't see
it.
I mean, I interned there. It was really
cool, but it's super grifty to be like,
"Oh, yeah, X Open AI. That's not my
style."
I got plenty of credentials without
having to pad it.
Well, just cuz I interned there, dude,
like putting that in my bio cuz I was an
intern there. Like, yes. Okay, I have a
blog. Like, I technically still have
this post from them and it became my
whole PhD, right?
It should still be on there. Yeah, look.
2019. So, this was one, how the hell
long ago? I was like 21, 22.
Uh, they don't have the um
Oh, I guess there's the old the old
client repo.
this is like this was considered a very
impressive RL result back then. Like RL
did not work at the time. All right, we
were training at I don't know maybe a
thousand steps per second and we had
algorithms that did not work. So
volunteer Twitch mod. Hey Muffin,
welcome. I see you on on X all the time.
Why don't you just hop in and start
building some cool projects with us,
man? It's all open source. It's how most
people get started.
You just like pick a small thing you can
do in a few hours, you know, see how it
feels and just pick bigger things from
there. It's pretty much how everybody's
done it.
I mean, when Spencer started, he had
zero zero RL experience. I don't think
he even really had any real AI
experience.
Um, several other people as well in
here.
It's also a great way to just jam some
nice low-level programming.
I'm going to deal with this Python crap.
Makes me sick. I'm going to be honest.
Ah, you [ __ ] You broke it.
You broke sweeps. You absolute buffoon.
Metric score goal maximize. It's the
default
This is me breaking [ __ ] and not
noticing it when I was in the process of
doing um I did a quick multiGPU
integration and then I had to go run to
do client work. So yeah, that's why I
like that's why I burgered it, guys. One
second.
Let me unberger this.
Hold on.
Playing with Puffer 5080 got fried. Oh,
okay. Rep. That sucks.
Yeah, that sucks. You do need a GPU of
some sort. Yeah, in time for four,
I will say. Okay, for whatever reason,
the vast chips are always giga slow, but
like if you just want something to play
around with and make sure that you
actually sync stuff
here
without having to spend like practically
any money.
3090s are 12 cents an hour.
Anything cheaper? You pretty much just
need a chip. Yeah, they got a bunch of
things. 5070 Ti. This is 10 cents. My
local machine has a 5070
and it's still on Puffer 4. I can still
get like four mil SPS, 5 mil SPS.
So, you can kind of just grab any
reasonably recent chip that can run four
and you can use that for dev. It's
pretty nice.
It's pretty much just like this. If you
want to get into this stuff, the sooner
you get started, the sooner you'll be um
building like bigger things. There's so
many cool projects we can do nowadays.
And I mean, realistically,
a lot of these useful M's are only a few
hundred lines of code. So, you have to
be a little bit creative about what
projects you pick if you want something
to be directly useful to research um at
that like at only a few hundred lines.
But like
I mean because a lot of like the really
common ones are maybe 600 to a thousand
lines maybe. But I mean here we use
breakout all the time. Breakout's a few
hundred lines of code. Uh 2048 I'd say
is more mediumish complexity. We use
that. Tetris is awesome. Slime volley is
awesome. Snake is really fun. This is
like 300 lines of code and we use all of
them in research.
Tower defense ends. Tower defense end
works. Tower defense is going to be a
little tough to optimize, I would think.
Maybe not that hard. You will have to be
a little bit clever because tower
defense games just have a ton of
entities. So, it's like if it depends
what the agent is. If the agent is the
thing placing the towers, you have to
make sure that the sim is pretty well
optimized. But you can do it. Discrete
versus continuous. I actually checked
that earlier today, Tim, and it seems
like the only thing that we usually run
continuous is the drone end. I did just
add continuous support yesterday,
though, and I made a quick test
environment to check that it was
correct.
TD is one of my favorite.
That's fair enough. It'll be fun.
It's a placement problem, which is kind
of cool.
I mean, I would think if we can if you
could solve a tower defense, you can
probably solve chip design.
37 cents for 5090. I do think that they
like they do something weird with their
chips sometimes. Like the uh the vast
chips are not as fast as my chips ever
are for some reason. But it's still it's
37 cents an hour is not bad.
On my 5090 I get um you know 14 mil SPS
up to that in training which is pretty
sweet.
Oh, do we not have down sampling?
Did I I did burger it.
How did I [ __ ] that up so badly? Holy.
I don't even know how I managed to do
that.
Hang on. Let me I got to fix my sweeps,
guys, because otherwise we're going to
just be I want to get to the gym, but I
need to get uh sweeps fixed first.
Oh, yeah. How are we on the 5k grind, by
the way,
guys? 29 stars. Come on. Star the
puffer. It helps me out a ton. It's
free.
Okay. Uh
dude, how did I just like delete this
code and not realize?
Huh?
I don't remember if I was using LMS. I
don't think I was. I don't think I
screwed it up because of that.
I bet it's this.
Yeah. So, hang on. We have all logs
in train rank
Yes, this is not good
because we want this to be
Hey chicken. Morning. This is towards
the end of the short morning stream
here.
this was one of the things, right? G
Snake.
Yeah, it doesn't have snake. It just has
scaffolding.
So I think we just get to delete this
and delete this, right?
These two params aren't used
and then scaffolding does get used
Give this a few runs. We'll see if this
works. If this works, then we get to
uh we get to hopefully start having this
end be part of our sweeps.
The thing I'm excited about for this end
is apparently it scales very well. Like
our best runs for this are 4 mil perram
models uh that are run for 7 billion
steps. So I'm curious to see with Puffer
4 if we can do better.
It's a little bit concerning that the
params are it's all the same size net. I
think this is part of the uh soil
though.
But still, like the original game being
solved under 30 seconds is kind of
nutty.
Oh yeah, and this is going to get faster
as well. This is with our vectorzation
being somehow janky.
There's a good path forward though. like
we get our initial experiments such that
we're pretty confident our sweeps are
nice and stable on at least a few of the
ends
and um we do all the cleanups over the
next few weeks and then we'll have a
final set of experiments and hopefully
there'll be some perf improvements along
the way just fixing buggy crap.
That is the 30
3800.
That's pretty crazy.
Okay, I think a couple more runs it'll
be into the um learned portion. And if
it's stable, then we'll just let this
we'll just like leave this running. I
will go to the gym. I will come back and
depending I might do an evening stream
or I might do I mean an afternoon stream
or I might do some client work.
Got quite a bit of stuff to get done.
Jim Good. Yeah.
And I'm pretty tired today, but I need
to get
I'm trying to think if I try to like
force a very fast 5K out of myself.
I definitely don't have a very fast 5K
in me.
I definitely have a 730 pace in me.
I'm trying to think. I don't know if I
have a seven pace or below in me. I
could also just do like um an easy
like 6 to 10 miles
and then some lifting.
Not sure yet. I figure out on the way
I might have a 703 in me. Let's say 8 8
and a half miles an hour.
I think this thing is just running
stable. I'm a little concerned though
because it's running the same the uh
same size network for everything.
It's just not playing with the network
sizes at all.
And
10:30 a.m.
This will at the very least get us a a
reasonable small model benchmark though.
Yeah, I think we'll let this just chill.
She'll be in the background.
I'm going to go get ready, get to the
gym. I will probably be back in the
evening. We shall see.
So, thank you folks for tuning in. I
will be live. What's today is today,
Friday. Yeah. So, I'll be live all day
tomorrow. Uh, if you want to help me out
for absolutely free with all the crazy
things I've been working on. You can get
involved in dev on the Discord or you
can simply feed the puffer star on
GitHub. It helps. We are 29 away from 5K
actual without rounding.
Follow me on X for more RL content now
and again.